hey Jen how's it going but that this
goes in here to plug this in today we
are making a grilled cheese tower danger
danger no we we have not had any
scissors all day long all day long let's
get it kitchen addition tongs maybe we
should just start discussing uppers okay
okay hey where do I stick this huh over
here I've never used one of these before
I just got it on the Amazon what's it
called it's called
is there a link in the description I
mean I can't I think it's like black and
decker but I don't even know it wasn't
blackest yeah Jenna open it for me what
are we doing all right we're making a
tower of grilled cheeses so what we're
gonna do is we heat this up Wow don't
put your hand on it after you plugged it
in butter we need butter I don't know if
you guys know but I was on an episode of
chopped I think was one of the coolest
experiences ever besides getting chopped
but I mean you guys seen my videos so
you weren't surprised surprise surprise
I got chopped but end of the episode I
said that my inspiration was grilled
cheese so today my inspiration is being
made it's actually my Twitter bio as
well well you do that Nathan said he
wanted some greens on his grilled cheese
and I said and fine but none of that
crap on mine I want sun-dried tomatoes
we've got those look at those for you
that's just totally we have four sticks
of butter I'm excited butter the bread
so wait well we're going to I was just
this is this is actually the inside of
it here's what we're gonna do how about
this will this be up to your standard
okay well listen listen this is Marc
this is boring this is this is butter
this is both side isn't it is that no
buttery I'm looking at you Nathan just
fine I think Megan is gonna be very
happy I smell smells like Bert Bert
metal
what's this probably my sis fire I love
cheese you know what when I was younger
I used to going to the fridge and get a
single slice of cheese and just eat you
oh I don't do any working I'm 27 and
partying I don't think I'm partying how
are we gonna make a tower it's gonna be
so easy look at this I'm loving grilled
cheese tonight do we want to put some of
these on or should we just wait after
this maybe after no I think like you
probably know more about cooking than I
do to be honest with you I really do mmm
oh yeah that's browning up nice okay put
this on here jeez oh my god my finger
don't open that up
Oh hurry hurry hurry I got grease burn
oh my God look at this beautiful Tower
Oh what's this a plate a plate mr.
Ronnie Wood we were playing uncooked
with Edie and right now I don't even
like the kitchen why are we rushing
because of the burning now okay thank
you here I mean yes great one oh boy yes
this is happening we're good we need
more cheese in between we should start
adding more cheese jeez oh my gosh okay
how did you do that oh well there's this
is taking all the fun out of cheese okay
Oh God
all right why don't we turn it down it
doesn't need to be on 400 no it does we
need a bar I did go burn okay what do
you think Nathan in this satisfactory oh
we went like this
oh my god it's small like soul fun we
got to take care of this first
what is this let's turn this back up
taking care of business the dog is very
confused and I must say I am as well one
second please
hot very very hot temperature Oh God so
hot well I have burned myself
nice times - okay start buttering and
getting some more things happening which
you need more bread burning I'm burning
everything I'm glad my body weight this
one has not moved it along as it has it
no he's very toasty what do you what do
you think we're making Nathan oh god oh
jeez Isaac tongs hey wait I haven't
moved this one in a while either Oh God
okay wait hmm got my inspiration is so
inspired oh my gosh is it hot
so we're enough to fill cheese powers
[Music]
it's like John I you want the colors are
so smart Sue's art although I've burned
myself on butter I don't like that noise
oh gosh are you doing what are you doing
honestly I asked myself that at least
once a day do you feel tired feels a
bunch of things
oh it's really greasy I feel super
greasy and I haven't even eaten yet I'm
making soup yeah what's the first rule
cooking don't believe the stove
unattended what are you yelling at me
you don't Burnie in handa no I don't
even wanna do war
oh god this one's burning I got put them
on here this is super sloppy super now
I'm gonna turn this down just a tad
we're gonna do is something but I don't
know if it's been done before no we
gotta melt there at the sides you know
get real grilled up so I think I'm
probably gonna be doing some health and
fitness videos soon because I feel as
though everything that I'm doing
not good for me looks good but I think
we need more butter literally I'm trying
you gotta comb your mouth okay this is
better to get it get the other side I
don't feel well cuz I'm looking at
what's inside okay go okay well we're
gonna put the spinach on I'll be fine
good idea I know what we need
hmm a drill uh I forgot my soap again
you just chose the recipes edges then I
think our our Tower is done wait
Islander know how many calories this is
I do the may have all we can do is
flipping him over Louie the stick the
stick
are you having fun I've got fire all
over your sweatshirt also to say that's
a very nice sweatshirt yeah seriously is
this like a hundred layers of grilled
cheese oh here's the problem we can't
get this thing out it's really hot Oh ah
no because it's it's
Oh God what I get the stick
don't give him the stick don't give him
the stick all right give him the stick
thank you mister you know like yeah now
stick it oh yeah baby
this is our dinner tonight yeah we're on
the soup again third time
[Music]
so this is our bread cheese Tower okay
how do we eat this okay I've got you
okay yeah we got a share hey there's
something good
oh that's good thank you so much oh my
god it's that look nice look at that
that is a layer that is a thing of
beauty
come on Nathan you got to try it I cut
my finger off I'm not sure my thing oh
my god I'm gonna hold it like a baby I'm
not sure what to do right now
shall we eat it
oh hey why does it would well it's
actually incredible as well not gonna do
that
I can't think this pic out well I gotta
go to hospital so what do I do now cuz I
have about 10,000 calories of grilled
cheese in front of me
eat up babe I got you I got cheese I've
got cheese I have to set this down well
I guess that's it
my inspiration is definitely grilled
cheese and it should be yours too
alright that's it I'll see you later
John get working on that soup Isis ooh
it's just like to have the soup with my
sandwich horsey see you later
[Music]
[Applause]